hello and welcome to this video playing
net trust 2000 hmm ok maybe do something
else here let's play the check pannonia
and sometimes play that so very closed
and to teach it you focused opening this
sounds that sounds like something that
should suit me the bad the bad news is
it's not particularly great so we'll see
what happens ok later three very early
see try to just try to play without the
movie form hmm doesn't ok yeah this kind
of setup with Bishop to e7 hun ya hear
um black has a couple of options I can
also play with 96 yeah i think but the
normal way is is is this kind of thing
in g 6 97 and f5
yeah why does yeah certainly going for B
form TM f5 or not yeah i'm not sure this
is a good move at the mode quite often
Black is also preparing this a little
bit more even now also wonder why should
kobe 6 here maybe okay i'm going to be
six supporting inside a little bit more
into t2 okay so i'm going for Knight f6
g8 this is a standard way of getting rid
of the bishop and then play a 5 later no
still white is probably somewhat better
you can play rugby one and try to invade
on the B file
groupie one looks very no but it takes a
long time in this position and I can
also capture ooh interesting yeah there
are two possible ideas connected to the
Muslim f1 or just 93 can also be that he
wants to answer f5 were there for this
is a very much possible I don't think he
wants to go at 4am but maybe with it
maybe he does I don't know my idea is 98
to bring the air to push the bishop bag
first we are now I expect Bishop b3
taking as a is usually a bad bad idea
okay if I go f5 now he very likely would
reply a form hmm
hmm question is if I can take f4 and
play g5 this is normally the idea okay i
think in still want to prepare that for
a moment but maybe he's still maybe he
just wants to go out for himself own i
would already seriously consider to go
out for here with white yeah and he does
it does as well yeah i should have
played a fire home definitely yeah i
know this is start looking good mm-hmm
that's a very passive position glad I
got here f6 er maybe f6 at least f5 is
not easy easily possible
Jeff my night said this these are really
really nice pieces they don't do
anything
try to go group b aid yeah this is
probably going to be decided in some
kind of x grabbed by a beef we are both
22 minutes now in a position where all
pieces are on the board maybe he wants
to go route to be seven
yeah maybe rupee 7 now I probably take
yeah then I guess route takes rupee
seven i think i have Knight to f6 when I
goes f4 okay let's activate a night at
least a little bit I look at you for ok
so this one ok I'm going to be seven no
that's not a threat even c 3 is hanging
so i can actually try to activate a
little bit my dear for it's not a threat
here at the pre stupid move that night
age 5 how about a stupid move
okay well again 95 is not on the thread
and I chief form but what does that
actually do I don't know but maybe I can
scare them a little bit then I'd be five
I just I just go back maybe he has some
night take c5 stuff that's it's possible
some tactics he i'm shooting for Bishop
g5 this is dangerous actually for him I
think I think you should go back now
between to be too and cover this if he
takes this will be dangerous I think
Queen III check around the corner
between be two looks look so sensible as
I would think I doesn't okay now we know
he plays it okay um how to do that nine
morning still not not easy at all here
some Queen have six maybe I don't know
doesn't do that much this one maybe it's
got seven seconds this is kind of
important i guess i have very likely
been on time check white forfeits i know
i think the position is also pretty good
check to check in there three yards
probably winning job he never got
something don't think read all of it
somehow I mean why was for why was
better and we had don't have to argue
there but i think it was still kind of
acceptable maybe i'm wrong that's it
certainly possible I didn't didn't want
to have such a passive position I think
my main issue here was that um I delayed
at five probably for too long I should
probably do it now I thought okay let's
prepare I am prepare it but it was a
very very bad idea I should just play an
f5 now I think white would go F for him
everything that he has played up to this
point indicates that affords his idea so
he will do this and now my idea was to
grab on f4 Bishop takes and now i was i
wasn't sure if i can get a g5 to work or
if that is too much it might be too much
this kind of thing it looks good yeah
you get this g5f forward it's not clear
that i have a good move now as you five
is threatened
Jim it's wrong idea I can of course take
and just play like this but yeah I'm
also worse yeah i'm not an expert on
this opening enter yeah yeah I'm clearly
clearly worse but i'm not sure how bad
it is and it's certainly not good here
but maybe you can still kind of for the
forward for a while kim this is what the
engine suggests Jeff the head and it
would have a good move here right now I
can do this but Kim yeah it's awfully
passer that's really awfully personal
you won't find a direct tail where that
then white can conserve but it's just
worse this however helped of course they
are taking only five yes um given up on
this tension release the tension I did
traders generally also helpful for me
because my space my lack of space so I
think I'm probably in the verses over
which also the engine degrees with
Knight f6 Queen between now and nine h5
was kind of yeah I didn't have a clear
idea when the move just wanted to look
scary but doesn't really it doesn't
really work and ok and Nyjah form now
maybe even that it's not threatening
much I mean okay 28 Bishop g5 is an idea
that has saw it okay taking
I don't I still don't think that white
has any issue here that cannot cannot be
true computer wants to go Bishop Queen
to be seven yeah here i was thinking
queen da them and if he grabs it Bishop
g5 this is indeed winning even for black
but he doesn't have to take this is what
the engine suggests this might be the
big problem now you're white seems to
white seems to win yeah and it's very
good for white so this is the the hole
in my concert the engine wants to play
Bishop f6 habit this is also clearly
clearly worse for black okay when he
played this and now he lacks the direct
continuation yeah that koo kumba cell
was just more aggressive this basically
losing a tempo and now i get this end he
still could have played this one and
this is an interesting suggestion check
this line given by the engine the slight
advantage for white has a quick cool
assessment and j that's a funny line
check and some I'm not losing
immediately amazing okay so he lost
another ten point now we had tides as
tide is turning and he lost lots of tiny
also in that that phase of the game yeah
and dangerous now it but now he's losing
way he was losing one time anyway it was
impossible to defend that correctly now
tough game where was in trouble most of
the time maybe never in like there was a
forced we know anything for him but it
was clearly clearly worse and not not
great to play yeah once in a while I
experiment with this opening but it has
its problems especially if you are not
an expert okay thanks for watching